[Music]
listen to me you were the furthest thing
from late
like 98 of the world doesn't even know
what it is 99 of the world has not
participated
like this is just starting
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation how are you if you've been
paying attention to me in any shape or
form over the last nine months you know
how much i am deep into nft land one of
the things that has really caught my
attention over the last
four to five weeks
is the thought of wait a minute you know
there's 50 to 100 to 200 of these great
projects coming out a day now
which is causing a supply and demand
issue and one of my great fears is that
people are day trading and really kind
of using nfts as an investment tool
which is great and i love that stuff and
i'm a businessman but
i do worry about oversupply versus
demand even though i think demand is
exploding by the day and people are
getting in by their ethereum and other
currencies to buy some of these nfts
i i am concerned by the sheer speed of
the amount of projects that are out
there and so i've been doing a lot more
archaeology work as my brother aj calls
it i've been looking back to the olden
days of nfts which takes me way way
way way way back to the year 2017 and
2018
when some of these projects started
hitting the scene
um and
one particular project really caught my
attention and i started doing some real
homework
as i've gotten more and more into the
nft land
whether it was chubbies or
fame lady squad i realized you know i
need to know a little bit more homework
about the human behind this project
because
sometimes the art is stolen sometimes
people claim to be who they're not and
you know
unfortunately and you know unfortunately
when you when you get a platform
it's required a little bit more homework
before you yap even though i make a
hundred trillion videos on twitter
and instagram and on this podcast saying
please don't buy what i buy i buy things
for different reasons i'm trying to
learn i'm not you know i'm i'm playing a
different game plus i've spent
years and i mean years
on you know putting myself into a
position to be able to
afford to take risk uh
and so even though i say all those
things people kind of jump and so i
start doing more homework than ever and
during one of those
i call them bingers because i get into
something and i'm just in it and i
discovered this incredible project
crypto strikers um that i was really
fascinated by uh an open c they're
called rap strikers we'll go into that
in a minute uh and and and now i do the
kind of homework where i reach out to
the individuals behind it and that is
how i
met
uh my guest on today's podcast and i
asked gianni to get on the show
mainly to talk about
2017-18
nft land because as you know if you're
listening
um i think history tells you the future
and i think there's a lot to glean from
the people that launched projects in
2017 and 18 and so i thought this be a
great opportunity for a lot of you to
learn about that era even though it's
five minutes ago it's a billion years
ago i mean it's a world of women a
project i'm very into today tweet
that you know we launched our project a
month ago we want to thank everybody i'm
like jesus that felt like 600 years ago
and so i'm really excited uh for this
guest to be here and so my friend why
don't you take the floor tell everybody
who you are a little bit about yourself
and a little bit about how the project
got kicked off
yeah awesome um super happy to be here
and kind of this is kind of caught us by
surprise because as you said you know
crypto striker is the 2018 project we uh
my partner and i
tell everybody who you are i apologize
tell me your full name your background a
little bit and then we'll get into ben
and all that too sorry
cool yeah no problem uh so i'm my name
is johnny cetino uh
born and raised in montreal studied
computer science i was working at a
fantasy sports company called draft that
ended up getting acquired in like early
2017
and i basically at that point like took
some of the money from the exit and just
like
i wanted to you know just do some
research on crypto i put it into
ethereum and ethereum just like
skyrocketed from there and i was like
all right you know now like a large
chunk of my net worth is in this thing i
gotta learn about it i actually gotta do
some research and figure out what it is
what's going on with this uh kind of
this new world of smart contracts and
and
programmable money so i started doing a
deep dive you know at the time the big
rush with icos the trading icos uh back
and forth but really what caught my eye
was late 2017 was uh cryptokitties which
was the first you know kind of
mainstream nft project so it was the
first it was the first one it was the
first one i ever you know i also bought
eat a couple years earlier
cryptokitties was the first thing that
i'd ever heard of and and i really wanna
not over regret because i just don't
have that
gear in me
but there was two or three times judy
there where i was like oh i'm gonna sit
down and really look at kitties
uh today and and i really believe had i
done that
all this insanity that is taking over my
life right now
would have started back then
i i do believe i'm a man of timing
you know i think my greatest strength is
understanding when millions are going to
do it not hundreds of thousands
yeah i think that i always think my best
skill set in business is when tens of
millions are going to do it versus tens
of thousands
i probably would have figured out in 17
my intuition i could be wrong about this
that it wasn't prime time yet
but [ __ ] i think i would have ended up
with strikers and punks and kitties and
some eve and who knows what the winds
would have done i'm clearly glad i'm at
where i'm at but man i wish those three
different times in 17
i feel or 18 where i was like let me dig
into it this weekend or this holiday or
tonight and i never got around to it so
to back up your point and i think for a
lot of people are listening here
cryptokitties was probably the thing
they heard
yeah and that was you know only a couple
thousand people using it but it was like
the first kind of mainstream success and
like i think it would have been really
tough to extrapolate seeing nfts then to
where they are now because that project
had like a little you know one month
peak a couple thousand people using it
but it never fully fully crossed and
captured the public's imagination like
nft projects did today so you know punks
they were giving them out for free like
you never would have known that punks
before would be uh whatever the floor is
today it's like some crazy stuff so i'm
kicking myself too i was i saw the
crypto punks website when they were just
free and you can claim your punk and you
know now it's like that was a pretty
expensive mistake looking back
um but yeah now that was you know so i
saw cryptokitties and i figured like all
right i i'm an engineer i kind of want
to build something i come from a sports
background played sports my whole life
uh the logical kind of step also given
that it was a world cup year that year
was making sports cards in the
blockchain so like the panini sticker
equivalent to you know having her panini
book and collecting stickers it's like
all right how do we use this kind of new
nft concept um
and and you know have these cards on the
blockchain where you can buy packs trade
them with people sell them on a
marketplace and that was kind of the
impetus for crypto strikers
one um
what happened like tell me like
you know obviously you're into it
you're digging deeper into you see
kitties you're like let me go even
deeper
and
get myself involved in it which is a
very mean move that's what
literally you did what i did with b
friends i'm like the only the way i
learn is by doing
what um
have it been come have your partner come
along did you guys know each other
and
i don't want to glance over the the
logical thing understand you're into
sports
world cup but i want to go a little bit
more into the details of like
what was different then johnny versus
what's going on now
like did you you know how did you get
your designers how did you think about
it obviously the rc standards were
different like go a little nerdy for
five minutes with me on this
yes i can start with how i met ben i we
have a mutual friend uh jeremy levine
who's like really big in the sports card
world in the fantasy sports world and i
was bouncing ideas off him and he you
know during one of our brainstorm
sessions he's like sports cards on the
blockchain like it makes so much sense
this is like one of those crossover
things that could bring mass adoption to
to uh to nfts and tokens and he's like i
know a friend of mine this guy ben he's
looking to work on a project like you
guys should totally sync up and then and
just get the ball rolling you know just
[ __ ] do it and that was kind of how
we met and then we started brainstorming
we're like look these things have to
look awesome like people are not gonna
buy them if they don't look good so we
started searching for designers we found
two different uh designers one in
montreal one in the i believe in the
philippines who made the two different
editions of the cards and we started
brainstorming these concepts uh all
right like how is the pack sale gonna
look like what's you know what's the
trading marketplace and then basically
like at one point was a hundred days to
the world cup or like all right are we
doing this or not like we gotta if we
wanna do it like there's a lot of
engineering work a lot of like pr work
to do so we just went heads down for
three months and basically on an early
early version of the erc 721 standard
which is you know if we get to the rap
strikers later i had to build a wrapper
this year to make them compatible with
open c and other sites because it's such
an older format we just went heads down
for basically 100 days straight and like
launched on day one of the world cup
did you literally make it for day one
yeah i think like i mean i didn't sleep
for the last week of it and like we were
testing stuff out like
the the nerdy thing you know if you want
to get into the technicals of smart
contracts like once you once you ship
them you can't actually change the code
they're on the blockchain forever
right it's not like for everybody who
gets like i'm not a developer but i've
worked with them
since 1996 closely i understand what
johnny just said like
we used to launch things like push out
things for winelibrary.com and it didn't
work and eric castner or john casamatus
would go back into the code fix
something and
push it and then i'd look at it it'd be
live for two hours we used to this was
like old school 96 when we didn't have
like a dev server so we'd be like
developing live on the internet because
there wasn't anybody really paying
attention anyway um
to your point this one this happened
with me with v friends there was you
know we did a great job because we were
going hard
but um we even had one slight error even
though we looked at the data seven
trillion times
you know uh with the anchovy and money
in my set was there any errors actually
when you pushed it no no we actually did
a bug bounty program opened it up to the
public said hey if you want to look at
our code and find it by we'll give you
money
someone found a small bug i think we
gave them like you know one or two eve
at the time which was you know a
thousand dollars or something but like
it saved us probably you know a large
loss had that gone live but yeah i mean
the contract ran perfectly fine never
any hacks or anything so that was like a
big success but it was definitely
stressful how big you know how do you
compare this era of nft craze to that 18
when things were starting to pop off
that first
wave
well i can give you like the numbers we
did in our you know our total sale of
cards i think was like 50 over the
course of a month and now projects
basically hire like a designer of fiverr
and they sell out like you know two
million dollars worth of tokens and
we're like one of the bigger bigger
projects like cryptokitties and then us
in terms of volume like the early early
open sea days and we had done like 50 of
sales basically so it's like microscopic
compared to what you're seeing today
and were you like pumped like wow we
really nailed it
yeah we were super excited because
people loved it we had like a really um
committed and like involved community
people like we're in the discord every
day chatting trading so like on that
note it was about success john i'm sorry
to interrupt you like tell everybody
about the discord culture back then
versus today same thing like it was the
main place where people communicated
i think crypto projects had started
using discord like the first time i used
zoom and discord was like in that era
like in the early 2018 when you know i'm
syncing up with designers for these
projects like other crypto guys picking
their brain but yeah it was the place it
was either telegram groups or discord
and discord is kind of better for like
managing you know channels and stuff so
we set up a discord and like during the
games during the world cup people would
come in and like live live chat during
the game so it was definitely um the
discord is like one of our highlights of
the community but that was the place
where early crypto projects kind of had
their uh people kind of gather and chat
why did the nft thing not gradually grow
why did it kind of die off and then
resurrect like what what did what's your
observation of
2019 or 2020 or or did they not die off
and they did graduate like what's your
perception on that
it i mean it's fully died off like we so
we tried to raise money off the back of
crypto strikers like look we had this
thing we ran it had a bit of success and
like investors just didn't really care
and like you know open c was around
superheroes around and like i really
respect those guys because they just
grinded it out for two years in a
full-blown bear market where like no one
cared about nfps um
but i don't know like honestly the ux is
really bad back then it's still kind of
bad for the average person to come in
and like
i thought the kind of the uh you know
what would trigger mass adoption of nfts
would be like the ux gets 10x better and
it hasn't so i don't know what's changed
why nfts like resonate more today than
they did two years ago i don't know if
it's a pandemic people stuck at home
people looking for kind of ways to
speculate on things um but for some
reason people just you know love the
nfts today like they didn't love them
two years ago but
it's hard for me to put a finger on what
changed
do you think investors struggled because
you didn't have the rights you know as
this project is resurrected i've been
obviously very involved in discord and
i'm a major collector of your project do
you think you know a lot of times people
bring up to me other serious collectors
like hey gary you know so rare i like so
rare better because they have the rights
you know like
some of the footballers are doing their
own direct products i didn't take a look
yet under the hood but messi did his own
thing recently here
was
was that an issue did that lead to you
to selling it because i know you in bed
sold the company like what was the whole
you know
there's i have a baseball card set that
i'm in love with from 1951 52 called
burke ross
that
this entrepreneur just made baseball
cards and put them into his cookies and
didn't talk to anybody about it just did
it
um
i think that was a little more
ridiculous because cards had been around
for 70 years and there was a call it a
acceptable protocol and a way to do
things i think what you and ben did it
was such early frontier
that you know i don't i i don't see them
the same
you know i think he would that that
entrepreneur in the 50s was a little bit
more
aggressive i think there was a little
bit
you know even talking think about what
you just said we had one of the most
successful projects that we did 50 eats
when eat was 500
right so
i'm just curious from that perspective
do you feel that was the interpretation
and what has been the history of
the fact that you know you didn't do
this trophy for the players
yeah i mean the goal was always to kind
of validate the concept and then you
know raise some money and then you know
do
either partner with an existing uh yeah
partner with an existing card maker like
we had very high level talks with panini
um back in the day we had you know we
could talk some other companies that
were rights holders and that was the
path we were going to pursue but the i
mean the thing the thing with you know
the leagues and the you know we had to
talk to the association stuff they have
really high like minimum guarantees and
there's like there was no way in 2018
2019 when no one's buying nfts to like
make turn a profit like people just
didn't care so it's like we can guaran
you know sign a contract pay them a
million dollars a year in mgs and like
what are we gonna do we're gonna sell
25k worth of nfts yeah so that's that
kind of you know that's why i respect
like the so rares of the world they just
kind of tucked it out grinded grinded
grinded and now they're in a really
really really good place i know you're
an investor and so rare and like they're
an awesome company we love them but they
were early crypto strikers users too
it's like they kind of yeah you know
yeah
but um
so let's talk about the resurrection so
you're living life you did this once i'm
sure you know back in the day
you leave the space i assume because
there wasn't anything going on and
that's at least what i can assume from
what i've seen from afar
all of a sudden
this you know nba top shot hits in the
fall of 2020
punks starts having things happen in
march of 2020 then june of 2020 then the
fall of 2020 and then [ __ ] gets
completely batshit crazy
in early 2021 you got characters like me
and cuban on cnbc you got people selling
for 69 million topshop punks go to this
and now we're in full pledge hysteria
nine months in
when did it
register for you that oh [ __ ] this thing
that i was so prominently involved in is
coming back
pretty early so i mean i i left the
space in the sense that like that my my
day project what i work on for my day
job is not crypto related but i'm still
like super
close and following the space a lot of
my friends still work in crypto so i was
like well aware of what was happening in
nfts i was one of the early probably
first 100 users in top shot i was in
their beta so seeing all this you know
and then you know january february 2021
you see nft is going crazy you're like
man i had an nft project three years ago
how do we start bringing this back like
how do i not miss this wave so i was uh
on vacation with my girlfriend i wrote
the rapper contract just to get the
cards working with the new exchanges and
it was just like explain explain explain
so everybody when you look for this
you've got to go to open scene go to
wrapped strikers not crypto strikers
when you search it explain what rapping
means i know it's a little nerdy but in
its most simplest form for everybody
who's listening
yeah so rapping is when you uh basically
take an asset and you lock it up in a
smart contract and the smart contract
gives you a new
asset that is compatible with a new
protocol a new website so basically it's
just like a one-to-one trade where
you're trading in the old thing you're
getting a new thing that works
everywhere so i think crypto punks you
know similar both they're not on erc721
so they you can wrap your pumps and have
wrapped plunks um there's a bunch of
other projects that have done that
mostly old projects just to make them
compatible you're swapping in the old
nfk for a new nft that works everywhere
now
johnny a lot of people ask me this if
ethereum
isn't destined to be the platform
will it be rapping or something similar
that makes people take nfts that worked
on ethereum and make them work on a
future blockchain that may be the winner
of 2030.
yeah i think that'd be more like
bridging is what people call that where
you're bridging assets from one
blockchain to another and like people
talk about this multi-blockchain world
where you know you have ethereum
coexisting with solana coexisting with
uh
like polka dot exactly and you'd be able
to port your assets from one to the
other um
i think ethereum has a really big head
start i don't want to pick any winners
just yet but yeah if ever some other
blockchain became dominant it would
involve bridging your assets from
ethereum over to that blockchain
do you consider ethereum in a place i
mean this is one man's opinion none of
us know i've talked to everybody about
this you can imagine for me i'm in a
spot where befriends was so successful
that i'm there i have a lot of beef and
i have to be very thoughtful about
diversification things that nature
um
you know
in your own mind do you ever think about
ethereum kind of similar to yahoo where
it's like okay yahoo i mean obviously
it's different things but we're talking
from a brand standpoint yahoo
kind of emerged as the winning search
engine from those early days and then it
did take something that was so much
stronger at it than yahoo
aka google you know five six seven years
later to kind of take market share do
you think something has to cut given how
far ahead ethereum is
uh and ethan's uh do you think it's
going to take something really special
to kind of move that pendulum
yeah i mean it might be like a second
mouse gets the cheese type situation
where someone just comes and does it
better but like as a developer and
knowing a lot of people who are
developers in the crypto space like
everyone's building you know
not everyone but a good 90 of the people
are building on ethereum so you have
this like network effects of the
developers so it would have to be like a
10x experience not for just the users
but also for the developers to switch
over because like end of the day the
people building products on top of the
platform or like if that's what's going
to determine the winner it's like you
can have the best blockchain in the
world if there's no experiences no yeah
and what and what about for web 2 like
websites i remember wine library was
originally on asp
then it was php
then it was
ruby on rails
python like do you see similar like
there it seemed that the language of
preference for developers tended to
evolve
it might the same thing might happen
here like the language for ethereum is
actually not amazing it's this thing
called solidity it's like a
theorem specific thing you know maybe
one day a blockchain comes or you can
just write javascript which is what most
people know and you can build amazing
apps on top of it i haven't seen that
yet um but yeah all i know is that today
most of the developer activity is on
ethereum whether that something much
better comes along and that changes i
think it's going to take a couple years
but for now ethereum to me is it clear
the clear front runner
what um what resurrected so going back
because i sidetracked you but i like
bouncing around so now you're like oh
[ __ ] this is all happening i have this
project that i is my baby of course like
any project i'm gonna write a rapper for
it so that the people that are sitting
with it can show up on that open c
so i assume that's where you were going
earlier that's what you did tell me what
happened from there
well i mean from there it kind of just
had sat pretty quiet until you found it
to be honest it's i was sitting
i was sitting in the discord one day and
people like yo who's this is that right
is there is that right there was no
other there was no other like
blip
one small spike i think the thursday
before you found it um it kind of like
we did 16th in volume that day and then
it came back down had a little bit you
know people were rediscovering these old
projects we had a little spike but then
i think the ether rocks came out and
like everyone rushed into the rocks um
but then you started buying up and i
guess you you did on your public wallet
people noticed and then that just
snowballed into madness but uh it was
basically you to be honest
and tell me the story what was happening
for you on your end you're like sitting
there and
i saw messages in the discord like uh
someone was like yo who's buying up all
these cards so i hop into the open sea
activity and i'm looking at the history
i'm like man this guy is like buying you
know one eighth here two weeks and like
loading up and then someone's like oh
you don't know who that is that's that's
garyvee by the way so i started doing
some digging started piecing together
the mystery um
and then i saw i believe the same day
logan paul was buying i'm like all right
something's up something's got to give
and then you know obviously you and i
you reached out to me we started talking
but that was kind of like you know
someone noticed it in discord i did some
digging and i was like all right like
what's what's going on here
and and so now what's been happening the
last two weeks
i mean we just had these crazy crazy
days like i think we were the number
like we were top 10
nft projects for a couple days i think
now we're like top 15. uh you know we
did more volume than like zed run top
shot so rare for a couple of those days
you had you know uh the draftkings guy
matt met khalid yes you had you you had
logan paul you had steve aoki like
seeing all these blue checks buying
cards it's been like really really crazy
um i think it's slowed down a bit from
that peak but i think people have kind
of it's been interesting to watch the
ebbs and flows
like
it's funny like
going through patterns now it's there's
so many projects it's like moments and
then like one one thing happens and
everyone gets you know
crazy again it's it's been interesting
what's been fun for me is seeing
a lot of old accounts wrapping in
yeah we've been tracking that number the
the wrapped percentage basically so i
mean just more context for people who
are not familiar with crypto strikers
there was 10 261 cards total that we
minted in 2018. so we sold them for a
month those cars
you know what i forgot that are you
10-2-6-1
yeah
because i know that the original the
original right yeah
that was deep fried
is 10 255 which is wild because that's
just
very unusual numbers by today's world
for us to be that close within each
other i like that keep going
well the crazy thing is like all these
projects today they do 10 000 on purpose
they like all right like we're creating
the supply of ten thousand we just like
sold all the cards we could once the
world cup ended we just stopped selling
cards and it just landed at that number
which is like kind of the standard nft
number today is ten thousand we just got
there by some weird accident and i guess
you guys probably got there by accident
too but yeah i know
i was very affected by punks that was
the thing i most taped into in january
and so
i
was aiming towards that number but i was
but i did characters with you know 20
then eight and five and just kind of the
math worked out that way and i was like
fine i'm also like not that anal i'm
like who cares like they ran a little
over it is what it is um
so
what's the state of the union right now
like what are you are you what are you
thinking about because you sold the
company
right
we sold parts of it we sold some of the
assets so it was actually a company that
had raised money to go do licensed nfts
uh and then the bear market hit and we
just we kind of pivoted to other stuff
and
mostly in the sports gaming sports
betting world um but they they own
certain assets certain assets stayed
behind in the llc so i mean ben and i
are talking because obviously now we got
all these eyeballs in the project like
what do we do with it do we
you know what are the options we haven't
figured it out we both have day jobs
it's kind of tough to
to manage this project which we thought
was in the past and what we're currently
working on but we're evaluating a few
options we definitely want to like be
supportive and be helpful where we can
for
you guys have been great custodians in
this court if nothing else and to remind
everybody who's listening
just because the way it worked back then
there is no royalties on this plus they
sold it i don't know what but but there
was no royalty contract right johnny on
on this um we didn't turn those on on
open safe yeah johnny was that was that
common in 17 and 18 the royalty
component or now
i found i found an old agreement between
open c and us because we were one of the
first projects in
and then we had signed like a rev share
where they got half the fees and they
got it you know we split the fees half
up but that was like for 2018.55 back
then yeah yeah it lasted only that year
that contract's done now there's no
royalties only open c takes their card
but like yeah the agreements are fully
different back then did you did yeah did
you look at it the other day and be like
damn i wish that you could take a look
and see if it's expired
yeah yeah i mean
i don't i don't mind honestly i just
want people to have fun with it like
we're not in it to make money we just
always thought this was like a really
really cool thing that we were you know
eventually if we had taken it full scale
we wanted to make money on it but at the
time just an experiment right so i
wasn't waiting for him to learn yeah of
course yeah what about for you as a
collector today what projects are you
into if any
um i mean i'm kicking myself i saw the
board ape contract when only 64 apes had
been minted and i could have just gone
and then minted a ton i sent it to some
friends i'm like i don't think this is
gonna sell out and next thing i know
it's sold out i missed that on apes um
i'm probably gonna buy a punk soon i
think you everyone i think you have to
own a punk that's probably the one
that's going to hold the value of this
yeah it's funny you say that every
everybody i talk to right now who feels
they're late and they're like man gary i
shouldn't i can't buy a punk now it's
100 it's a lot of money first of all but
the ones who can afford it i'm like
listen to me you were the furthest thing
from late
like 98 of the world doesn't even know
what it is 99 percent of the world has
not participated
like this is just starting and i agree
with you on punks for that reason
yeah i think that's the one you know
it'd be really stupid for me to be in
nfts to the extent that i am and not own
a punk so i got to figure that out and
buy one pretty pretty soon before the
floor yeah i think you should go up
another 10 yeah i think exactly
um but you are looking at projects
constantly and things of that nature
yeah i'm always like you know i've been
kind of looking at that on1 project that
came out the other day i try to get in
on drops just because i can code so i
try to write a bot get in on drop
sometimes flip them keep some of the
ones i like but uh but i think you know
for long-term holds punk's apes those
are the ones that are really gonna hold
value
any parting shots before we get out of
here brother
nah dude it's been it's been awesome
getting to know you it's been awesome
you've been like really involved in our
discord so people are always stoked when
you drop in and say hi so don't be a
stranger i'm happy that i won't i won't
everybody who's here listen if you love
proper football if you understand where
soccer sits on
the pedestal in society you know what's
great about you know the blockchain is
it's transparent uh it's been very
important to me that i don't hide behind
i'm not i don't own any wallets people
don't know about i have the gennady one
that sits with earphones which is my
russian name and i have
gary.befriends.ed
and
you know i uh i love that because i with
sports cards
you know i went in very heavy four years
ago
and just the amount of people that want
to just start rumors of like gary's
selling these behind the scenes of the
pump and dump and i always like my
reputations my is my life and i would
get so frustrated to the point where
like in a lot of ways it turned me off
with sports cards it's like what do i do
i can't enjoy it whereas with this
i love it i can enjoy it right like if i
want to buy if i want to sell it's all
there like there's no you know like
hidden agenda um and
you know i uh
i'm very fond of your project i mean
thank you so much for introducing me to
the the artist who did the iconic work
like i i facetimed him the uh today
actually was it
today you know i'm just i'm trying to
like help him and bring him do some work
for with him like just love his art but
he did a great job and like my ronaldo
and messi like iconics like i'm i'm
completely obsessed with your project
the the way you structured it the moon
boppies with the star i like
and and very honestly
like maybe this is probably
counterproductive but i love being
honest with my my um audience i'm loving
this little lull i've noticed this being
a pattern explosion a little low
explosion a little low i've seen it with
punks now for nine months i see it with
beet friends right now i think the
friends is like um an interesting lull
opportunity right now
but i'm enjoying the slow i'm hoping to
see how long it could go because i'm
surely not done adding to my striker's
collection so i i hope we cross paths a
bunch of the future brother and i and
congrats on putting together one of the
projects that
long after both of us are gone and
people dig up the bones of this era this
is gonna be one of the projects they
point to
for sure thanks gary this has been great
take care
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight this is the time to
subscribe i hope you consider it and i
hope i see you soon
you